avec les animaux c'est comme avec les
hommes il ne faut pas trop se fier aux
apparences
par exemple il ya des mots belliard qui
ne vivent pas en franche comté et il y à
des vaches de franche-comté qu'ils sont
pas des mobiles yard
moi j'ai choisi la race qui est élevé
dans ma famille depuis quatre
générations au moins on a toujours aidé
et virgin dans notre exploitation et on
est fiers de représenter la race
vosgienne de franche comté ont diane
saint bresson elle est adaptée à notre
milieu de vie parce qu on est dans l'est
située dans le massif des vosges
on a au sud du massif des rouges une
zone tout proche des mille étangs et on
a des terrains difficiles et c'est une
gauche très rustique qui s'adapte très
bien à nos environnements
c'est pour ça qu'on a choisi la
vosgienne et que mes arrière grands
parents ont toujours élevé de la
vosgienne et qu'est ce que vous faites
de votre lit nos clients pour notre
temps ou transforment 100% de notre lait
à la ferme pour faire une tomme qu'on
appelle coeur de massip qui est fait
exclusivement les vosgiennes on
transforme depuis peu de temps mais je
pense qu'à long terme savait que cette
transformation à la ferme ça va me
permettre de dégager un meilleur revenu
qu'est ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
[Musique]
ça c'est votre fromage exactement c'est
le coeur du massif donc produit 100%
oled vosgienne qui vient du massif des
vosges
c'est plus marqué que le conte est un as
et plus marqués pourtant par mois
d'affinage
à croire qu'on est des bons formats g
dans les vosges nous voici dans le hall
6 c'est un rendez vous incontournable
pour toute personne qui veut voir la
franche comté au salon c'est le sens des
chevaux comtois mais comme vous allez le
voir
tous ne sont pas élevés en franche comté
pourquoi le comtois mon père a acheté
une jument de trait parce qu'il aimait
ça en 2003 une toise et voilà on est
parti avec ça et on a été qualifiée pour
le national avec cette jument cette
première qu'on a acheté et après on est
monté d'un coup nationale à mèche le
massif central
à bientôt plus de chevaux comtois que
dans le doubs voilà quand washington 6
et un cheval c'est à cheval lourd mais
en même temps et salle allure savent ça
la classe qui aime quand ça se déplace
[Musique]